get ready to shift your moral compass
from white to grey because this story
concerns software pirates who will
worried they won't be able to pirate
anymore due to drm advances yeah it's
tricky to pick a side on this one
Chinese cracking group 3pm are having a
bad time of it as their finding it
difficult to digitally steal Just Cause
33 DM forum founder bird sister and one
more time that was indeed bird sister
said in a blog post I still believe that
this game can be compromised but
according to current trends in the
development of encryption technology in
two years time I'm afraid there will be
no free games to play in the world 3dm
efforts to crack the de nouveaux
anti-tampering measures for Just Cause
pre-approved unsuccessful the new vote
is a secondary encryption system that
adds extra security measures on to
existing drm dragon age inquisition also
employed the system and managed to
remain sturdy for a month before pirates
cracked it which if you didn't know is
apparently a long time in game tracking
pirates world drm has always been a hot
button issue and Aunty of publishers
have weighed in on it Ubisoft previously
said that DRM cannot stop piracy while
the witcher developer said app react red
hub called drm the quote worst thing in
the gaming industry let me know what you
think about drm and whether you think it
will ever be able to keep the pirates at
bay in that comment section be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot for all the
latest
you